you know it's like we started
with Jonathan Majors Jonathan Majors
Jonathan you know over the years what
has been like the day-to-day change that
you've seen since your star has really
been rising
probably more pictures of my daughter
standing in front of posters you know
that's kind of fun oh did she send does
she take pictures then send them
hey but no truth of the matter is I you
know
now it's the other part of the business
you know they don't talk about in drama
school like you got to promote the film
you know and like
I can stand by all the pictures I've
made you know so past you know a few
months you know I've been promoting the
film you know I think if there's going
to be a moment of oh you know I mean
there's a bit more you know Mr majors
and I kind of shut that down immediately
Jake is fine bro Jay is preferred you
know you'll know when to call me Mr
Majors you know what I mean I'm giving
you that energy but for the most part
nah does your baby girl get it did she
get it I don't know I think she's just
she's just happy yeah I mean like that
and that's all I can hope for you know
like
yeah I mean she know she knows I I'm an
actor yeah I mean
um but I've been an actor I've actually
been an actor her entire life she
doesn't know me anything you know we
don't live in hotels anymore you know
she knows that so yeah
you make me cry
so
[Music]
how long have you known each other
it was like brothers
all right have you been able to sit and
like think about the fact that through
Creed you are now a part of this iconic
Rocky franchise I mean we you know this
is kind of the soundtrack of my life
these movies and they're they're iconic
have you thought about that one
I think if I would have uh
I mean it's it's like a it's a it's a
it's a mind trick isn't it you know
where you go
there is no spoon you know there is
there is no I'm just I'm just making a
movie exactly
um because I think it's just the
overwhelming uh honor of that you know
is uh it's quite beautiful you know so
I'm happy yeah Michael tried to lie and
say he didn't he didn't know his body
fat at the peak for this movie oh you
said that he tried a lot I know look
y'all got an incredible shape do you
know yours I mean was this the most
physically demanding or physically fit
that you've been and I don't know if it
blended with Kang and and you know
Damien the bodies are different I have
lower lower body fat in
um magazine dreams
he has a bodybuilder film
um this is probably four four percent
four percent and that's probably four
points yeah four percent lower than four
percent body fat all right now I'm right
now I'm probably
[Music]
I'm probably four now but also probably
six pounds heavier than a day wow yeah
it's a lifestyle yeah it's a lifestyle I
mean
protein protein shake there we go
so this is for you it wasn't like let me
really get in shape for this movie it
was let me maintain and then up what I'm
already doing
it's upper yeah we definitely have to
definitely have to gun it you know and
get more specific you know I'm going for
overall health I'm going for I mean I I
actively don't show my body I wear big
clothes did before the film you know
it's not a thing you know it's that's
for me you know and then for whoever you
hear me
um so yeah you know so this was the
first time I was like okay it's gonna be
on display more or less you know and as
we talked about like the
um
the honor of joining you know the Creed
versus the rocky verse and you're the
new installment you want to you want to
do right by everyone that's come before
you you know you want to do right by you
know when you write with my brother and
go I'm gonna you want a bad guy you want
a form of the quote
Here Comes yeah well there was one shot
in the film it was you from behind I
think you were staring out the window
and you just like breathe your traps
moved I was like this man's muscles like
he didn't
it's like this is some stuff this is
wild
um you told me a couple weeks ago that
you gave Paul Rudd harder punches harder
punches
Ant-Man or Adonis Creed receiving or
giving oh did you hit him harder
receiving a giving
okay I definitely received
oh this is I can't say that I've
definitely I definitely gave harder
punches to
um
probably Paul because there was no
gloves on so there'd be camera angle and
so I would throw the punch that way it
was it would appear because if I hit you
for real it it actually wouldn't catch
it so where the camera is You Gotta
Throw the punch that way very much like
theater you know stage Direction so you
know you know
um yeah but for the most part if it was
if it was below the chin it was hit you
taking it I mean like literally we would
go home and like there'd be either
raspberries all over you yeah it was
like it's quite it's quite cool you know
because at one point at one point the
makeup uh artist was like uh yeah that's
real like I'm not really to add anything
like you've got that yeah you're just
like that's real you know yeah yeah do
you have a favorite onset memory of
Michael the director that you can share
yeah I think at the end of the Montage
in the Montage it was dark but I could
see there was enough light to see his
face and we finished it that boy came
around that corner just like
you know when I was like my brother's
happy yeah my director's happy you know
what I mean because I just because all
fields of what we were doing you know
what I mean like the Montage is a part
of the the Creed Rocky world like gotta
have a wicked Montage like if your
montage is trash I'm gonna tell you like
yeah
it was great montages you know what I
mean so I knew he wanted that and when
he came out and I saw that he's my man
now so I saw his face and was like
oh you happy with that I'm like
okay great great you know
[Music]
foreign